Zona or that a general path? No, no, no,
but we had, but mostly people were in that were in my group was trauma,
but there was sex addict.
I mean, there was, there were addicts.
That whole thing, the red, yellow, I had to write that chart as well. Right,
right, right.
And is that curtailed to each person? Like what that looks like? Okay. For sure.
So some people will have, like, you know,
if I act out with pornography, that's relapsed other people, you know,
not so much, like for me, that would be the yellow light behavior,
even though I just don't with that.
But for me, it was like going to strip clubs was not in the thing.
And then that my therapist or my counselor was like, no,
that should be in the red. I go. Why? Because he goes to,
he was telling me that because by you partaking in that, right.
These women, not all, but most right.
Or some right. Also are people who are victims of trauma.
Right. And it's just your site. You're, you're feeding into that,
you know what I mean, a cycle. Right.
And so I remember putting that into that porn was in that, you know,
and, um, the banana massage parlor,
what's the banana tug, which one's that one.
Address or whatever. Is there a one called the banana massage?
I thought you were promoting one. I'm like, is that on Fairfax?
The massage joint.
Yeah. You know, it's funny with the massage joints before I met you, my friend,
my friend and I, right. He's like, we should just do it right now.
I've never done it before.
So we went to a place and a place that he normally goes to,
and there was a gate and I had a duck. He had to bring it, you know,
you have to ring up, do a buzzer and that hello.
And a woman looked through the window and she goes, no,
she looked at me and she goes, no. Then we went to another place.
Same thing happened? No. But did she say yes? Yes.
Because she had been at both places. So I thought I looked like a nark.
Do I look like a narc?
I wonder if, because it's such a predominantly Asian thing,
like massage parlors. I don't know if that's, I don't know. I don't know.
You looked at my brother, right?
The it's the, um, the Asian model, minority myth.
They don't want to see you go down like that. They're okay.
Seeing the white man go down, but not, not our brother.
That could be it. It could be it.
Or maybe, maybe they, they, uh, they don't want to be,
they don't want you to see them doing that.
Shame. Yeah. How horrifying would it be if you see this? Right.
So I'm gonna open up a curtain and you go, mom, it was your mom.
That would be a nightmare worst. Right.
Cause then I would have to get in there and just to try to fix it.
Cheers to us, man. Congratulations to us. Isn't it great. Like to not have like,
you know, like all of the,
the attendant stress I've like
and deal with with me. And I was just like one of these jerks where, you know,
like I got I'm super into the girl and then like,
I hook up with them and I'm not into them anymore. You know, like that whole,
it was,
it was just like sociopathic this pattern of like,
you know, uh, pouring on the charm, this like, like, you know, um, and,
and really feeling like we batch equated with,
with the woman and pouring on the Chimp, groping her in, it was just like the,
you know, the,
the equivalent of just being like misleading and exploitative and
then neglectful and then abandoning, you know,
like it's just up, man. And, and,
and the shame that I would have, like when, you know,
when I went through that cycle, it was like, God, you know, I hear,
I burned someone, you know, like I just burned someone with the ghost routine.
Like I would feel my self esteem was just
nonexistent.
And I think that whenever we're in a position where we are feeling
victimized or resentful,
it's the really helpful thing to be able to put yourself in the shoes of the
person, towards your feelings.
Hey guys, we're going to take a quick break to show him.